hey caitlin hey have you ever wanted to
turn
something that you really enjoy doing
into your full-time job so much that you
and your significant other
quit your full-time jobs without really
having any idea what you're doing
yep
that's an intro i'm kind of
standardizing on like the the hey
caitlyn intro
yeah you caught me off guard because i
didn't realize you were already
recording us i was waiting for you to
push the button
and that's why i was just like hey
you couldn't even say hi evan back you
don't even know who i
am i was just caught so off guard
um hi everybody so today we're going to
be talking about um
turning your hobbies into your full-time
job i think this is gonna be
hopefully a good podcast for anyone who
has thought about what it'd be to turn
something that you enjoy into a full or
part-time job which it seems like
there's a lot of these days
yeah i think especially with people
spending more time
at home right now it's kind of like hmm
maybe i could do something productive
extra because i can't go out of the
house you know
yeah and obviously this worked out well
for us
it's it's not an easy road and it
doesn't always turn out well but
that's kind of like starting a business
in general yeah today
we're more talking about like pros and
cons
of starting a business based around your
hobbies yes rather than just
pros and cons of starting your own
business because the pros
for us certainly outweigh the cons but
we want to be honest with you guys too
there are some
some cons hidden in there but i think
before we get into that
i think it'd be funny if we didn't know
what's new we haven't done what's new in
a long time what's new with you baby um
i wanted to say one thing and i like i'm
not not that we're going to commit to
this going forward but i want to like
make note of this moment
for the longest time we are just focused
on
getting the company that we're doing
right now running
like evan and caitlin we were focused on
growing and growing it yes and then
i don't know maybe a year ago we started
adding back in like
like evening time at the end for us and
this is interesting because like it kind
of goes
i'm going to touch on these later like
into the pros and cons like
less than a year ago actually less than
a year ago we started like
reading and taking personal time off and
you start reading until this year
wow yeah so maybe not in my life
and we've finally gotten our live to the
point where we've been able to add
workouts back into our day yeah it's
been really nice i just kind of want to
like take a moment
to acknowledge the success
i don't know why i always you want a
handshake but i can't take a silence not
good for podcasts okay
unless there's like a handshake noise
like what if it was really wrestly and
we were like
we're just rubbing our hands
we're like evil villains like
yes we have started working out for
those delicious games
for all the games to get so small
also it's it's also interesting that
like this year we've been trying to like
pull back
on videos but also like i just want to
take this
moment to acknowledge that we did five
we're going to be doing by the time this
podcast has come out we've done five
videos in a row and some of those have
been cooking videos
we haven't done five videos in a row in
over a year
yeah so it's crazy that like we we've
been able to get kind of our life
in order a little bit and we've been
able to add working workouts back in
which is something we've been wanting to
do
for a long time and we have five videos
yeah
and we're talking videos on the main
channel obviously on gaming and uncut
and all that there's
there's a bunch more yeah and we've been
able to like step up
our live streaming game like we've been
doing video games
on the live stream for how many years
now
maybe two years no because we started
around christmas so
it's not full two years yeah i think
okay year and a half or so okay
a year and a half but now we've started
adding in like we did a cooking live
stream
we did an art live stream and you know
we're like we're enjoying
the garage live streams enough that in
the background
um i've been researching how to like
upgrade our garage setup a little bit
more i have a new more powerful
computer for out there and that's in
progress so that's
that's kind of what we've been up to
somewhat behind the scenes even though
you guys
know some of it like the five videos but
it's like the
i like is it kind of hard to do the
what's new section because so much of
our life
is work which is so you guys already
know what's happening
yeah oh i have a what's new oh what's
that what's that so
our speaking of the garage streams our
most recent garage stream
was we did a second attempt at the
cheese uh-huh
um you know after doing our diy cheese
video
i had it for a snack and it was tasty oh
yeah
it aged it it aged well
past few days yeah so it is kind of
interesting like i want to do the what's
new segment but really
all of our life most of our life is work
and is public
and we don't do much outside of that
well
most of the stuff that you guys would
find interesting you know like there's
stuff we do
like like oh i mean
we hurricane prepped and then we need to
yeah and a lot of the work that we do
isn't
like publicly shown like caitlyn spends
so much time editing
i spend a ton of time prepping i've been
working on like a spreadsheet of
video games that might be fun to play so
so there is a lot that goes on behind
the scenes but it just doesn't make for
interesting things to share
yeah i don't know the spreadsheet of
games it has been kind of cool
we actually heard about that on a
podcast yeah so like
maybe maybe game spreadsheets is a good
idea so i have like
the active games we're playing the two
play with
rankings and stars and like the types of
like
genre it is how many hours the game is
how many hours it takes and then like
the evaluating column and then like the
pending release column like
cyberpunk 2077 is in there with a
five-star
rating of like pending release i'm
excited about that you know
okay all right enough nerd stuff let's
get on to the main topic all right so
turning hobbies into work and let's like
outline some of the hobbies that we have
turned into works do you think that
might be a good place to start i think
the most obvious ones
are things that videos are about so
that's like making
crafting art uh then we added video
games
yep then we've kind of recently added
cooking
although i don't know if you can really
call cooking like a hobby per se since
you got to do it to live
but it is something we enjoy but i mean
there's like different levels of cooking
there's cooking to survive and then
there's cooking to enjoy the cooking
well yeah
i do enjoy the cooking so cooking yeah
and then there's like
a few other things that aren't really
hobbies but they are things we did
before um turning them into work that we
don't do now so that's like
social media um
like social media outside personal
personally yeah
um uh filming and editing little just
for fun videos yeah and one that i
thought of that like is a weird thing to
think about like
when i was when both of us were working
separate jobs one of my favorite thing
to do
was spend time with you that's not
really a hobby but like
it is something that has we have
monetized
in a weird way so weird yeah
i mean it's like it's kind of the whole
choice i mean like
like like all of the things we talked
about making
art games cooking like those are what
we are physically doing and that's what
the videos are about but really
it's more about the two of us spending
time together yeah the whole reason we
started
the channel so that is actually a pretty
good example
um so should we like talk about how some
of these things have changed because i
think they've changed in different ways
how they've changed and then maybe some
pros and cons or something
of like um yeah pros and cons of of
doing
your hobbies for work which i think that
can kind of be broad i think that
the biggest thing that has changed is
how much of these things do we do
outside of work
yes because before they were our work
they were our hobbies
and now that they're our work do we do
them in any hobby capacity
anymore yeah and the answer is
not really i for me but i don't
forget for me some which ones do you use
gaming
oh yeah you do i do i do game out
is to test games that we are considering
for the gaming channel or sometimes like
you know for
like you know this is getting into the
weeds of gaming but like one of the
games we were playing astroneer involved
a lot of prep
so in the evenings i'd sometimes play
that
to prep for the stream to prep for the
stream which like made
my game gaming
more meaningful in a way like
well focusing in on the gaming thing um
because that that is an interesting
example
because it is something that it's a
hobby we had kind of both
lost because we didn't have time for it
and so with that one it it's pretty much
all pros for us in terms of turning that
hobby into work
because if we hadn't turned it into work
we just wouldn't be doing it
yeah and i think that that's something
that you can kind of apply
to anything like let's say fishing was
your hobby
but you get so busy with life
that you just don't like you just can't
muster up the
like importance the priority of fishing
to like add that back into your life but
if you can
make it mean something more by turning
it into a job or
like something that like
adds to your life in other ways if
you're like oh i'm gonna or
i don't know if there's fish at farmer's
market are there fish at farmers markets
okay if you grow tomate if you if you
garden as a hobby
and you're like man i don't have time
for gardening anymore but then you're
like oh there's a
every sunday farmer's market i'm going
to grab some tomatoes and sell my
tomatoes
you know that kind of like helps you
remake it a priority because there's
something
that that hobby is leading to other than
only your enjoyment of it and i know
like
your enjoyment should be enough but as
an adult
priorities like your your time is
stretched
thin often so you can't do everything
you would like to prioritize
well but also i mean i think that that
this seems weird to say
because seems like such an old person to
say
but i'm gonna say it anyways when i was
young a young boy i could just play
video games
oh sam and that was a meaning
unto itself that was all i need it's
like i like playing video games
i'm gonna play video games for hours yep
and as i got older like
aka when i started working a full-time
job
that became harder
that became how do you how do you say
this it was harder to like
to prioritize it prioritize it and
i just remember there's like so there's
there's a weekend that stands out into
my mind a lot
i was single i was working a job that
paid well
it was fairly easy satisfying it was an
engineering job i was happy
with it generally and it was a weekend
and i had like the whole weekend open
and i'm like you know what i'm just
going to play video games
all weekend long sounds nice yeah it's
like
like young evan
like think oh that's so cool you have
this
super cozy couch it has a recliner you
have money
you can go out and get take out food and
you can like do whatever you want
you're an adult and i play and it was a
good game it was a great game
skyrim awesome game it's like especially
it was like
soon after it came out it was like kind
of like
i'm not sure if it was groundbreaking
but it was great especially like
it's still good now but like imagine it
like
however many years ago i get it anyways
at the end of the weekend i was like
what was the point of that what did that
do to
for my life it took up my time
and i don't really have much to show for
it
and that was a weird concept for me to
struggle with because shouldn't the
enjoyment of it be
enough enough yeah
i know it is it is weird anyways
that was the start of my like not
downward spiral of gaming in my life but
like
because that sounds too dramatic but
like it was harder and harder to
prioritize
gaming and that was before we started
the youtube channel that was before we
were dating
that was before we were dating yeah yeah
we did play some games together
well i think i mean we're going deep in
the rabbit hole of gaming but
i think treat gaming for whatever
hobbies you might enjoy
listener you know i think it's also
different um like if you're
gaming as a social thing like with other
people
either in person or online that's a
little different than playing by
yourself
yeah um but yes i think that's an
example
where um like it it has only been
positives
adding it back to our lives
yeah um at even though we had to do it
as work
and that's you know the reason we
started the gaming channel is we wanted
to play video games
again but we knew we could only do it if
we could prioritize it because
you know we were making commitments to
people saying we'd be online and stuff
like that
and this is this is a point i didn't
really mean to bring up right now but
i'll bring it up
now just because like it seems relevant
and i'll i might touch on it
later with the other things the other
topics that we've
made from hobbies into work
doing that the main pro is you get to do
what you love
and eventually once you
have made it successful you do get more
freedom
in a way because like when you're just
grinding
there isn't as much freedom because if
you really want to make it a success you
just need to work
work work work by it you mean a business
around
which yeah you turned a hobby into a
business
because like right now i mean like i
think how many years into this
three years over three and a half over
three and a half years into
the evan and caitlyn business i
i really feel like we're getting some
freedom but for the longest time we were
kind of like
tied into the job and that was the
number one priority and
though we did have some freedom and we
were we were the ones getting ourselves
into this
i didn't really feel like that huge of a
sense of freedom because
we you know needed to make money and we
had commitments to brands and we had a
schedule and
we had all this to figure out and we
were kind of like
tied into that in a way but like
i think the the the things to keep in
mind
when you're saying okay so we were
adding gaming it was a hobby now it's
work it has all this more meaning and
stuff
but i think that one thing that we've
done a pretty good job of
is like trying not to lose sight of the
reason why we're doing this is to do
something that we love
and not turn it into something that is
an obligation like
for example if there was a video game
that was like trending
and it was like going like everyone was
wanting to watch it everyone was wanting
to watch it but it wasn't a game that
you enjoyed
if it was if you're only thinking about
it from a work perspective
then you would play it yeah and you'd
capitalize on that
but if you weren't enjoying it that's
like losing the
losing the losing sight of why you
started doing it in the first place
that's so true that's such a good point
and like we do
often remind ourselves that
we want to enjoy what we're doing and
that
helps us from taking on too many
responsibilities or
you know using the example you said
doing something just because it's
trending
unless it's something we want to do
anyway yeah you know
um and i think that is a really good
thing to keep in mind
and i think that the the interesting
thing
is with the gaming there are just more
pros one thing that's
weird is with the making crafting art
yeah section i think there are slightly
more cons that i can touch on
touch away
okay i think that the biggest thing is
when you turn a hobby into work
the the main complications is
it adds pressure and expectations you
know
like because but before if i was making
a piece of artwork
sometimes it would be bad it would just
i think i have like a piece of artwork
up there in the closet stack of evans
reject art
and like when you're just doing things
for a hobby there it doesn't matter if
it
performs well or if it turns out well or
whatever yeah now
i think the biggest example where this
shows up
in how it affects our lives is we are
making videos that we want people to
click on
and watch and the click ability
in terms of the title and thumbnail
really dictates
what projects we take on in a in a
fairly big way
especially in the last like year year
and a half
yeah i think that i think in the very
beginning when when we
i mean we didn't have as many skills in
making we didn't know how to do as many
things
we kind of focused more on stuff we
needed so it was like oh we need a dust
collection cart
we'll make a dust collection cart and
now i'm like i wouldn't want to do it
like a basic shop project not because
there's anything wrong with it
but just because like for our type of
videos it's not
the most intriguing thing to click on
yeah or like
you know one of the things i'm really
proud that we made with our hands
is this beautiful walnut entryway table
with finger joints
it's beautiful i love it me too
i'm proud that we have made it but it's
not that clickable of an idea
there is a video on it there's a video
on that and the desk collection card
yeah
but like it is it's weird to think back
way back in the day
of making that and then honestly
in terms of our enjoyment
i've really been enjoying the recent
videos that are clickable that have
interesting
thumbnails in terms of our enjoyment
like filming them
we have so much fun when it is like a
little bit crazier or a little bit
goofier or we get to do something
for the first time like the video that
will have just come out when this goes
live is the biverse diy where were you a
mold of our
hand like those curious yeah and like
that that's one thing that i like you
know it's like
part of the reason why i like making
crafting is learning new skills
following rabbit holes of like what like
what would happen if we learn this skill
or what have you and we're still doing
that
but it is uh it is weird that there are
restrictions like um
honestly if we weren't making videos
around this like if we had
all the money we would ever need for our
entire lives and
all of that like one thing i might do
more of is 3d printing like honestly
for me and the videos that we make it's
it would be hard for us to make
lengthy entertaining videos around 3d
printing because
you just you just push the button push
the button it goes you clean it up
and there are great content around 3d
printing but it's usually
around the 3d printers it's around the
technology the nozzles this and that the
whatever
but it's not around like the making
using 3d printing
and we have done some where we combine
3d printing with woodworking etc etc etc
yeah but it's hard for us to do
a video that's only 3d printing just
because i i like 3d printing and stuff
i'll do more designing and making of
little doodads and gizmos and gadgets
because
that makes me happy in a weird makery
way
so i will say even though we are like
perhaps more restricted in some ways
because we
want to do videos that will get clicked
on so that means
some kind of practical around the house
things we just don't make
um on the flip side we
are also opened up to more types of
projects that we probably wouldn't ever
do or or get to try if we weren't doing
it for our business
like resin resin is like it can be very
expensive if you're doing something big
and like i don't know if we could
justify
using you know 25 50
100 200 worth of resin and a project if
it was
you know just like for our house
underwater stream
oh the underwater stream yeah that cost
thousands of dollars
thousands of dollars for us to do that
and
there's no sponsor yeah no we obviously
we we wouldn't have been able to justify
doing that project even though it was
something we were so curious about and
excited about
it's hard to justify it if you can't
like justify it as a business expense
yeah
and then during the making of that i
felt the most like
i really love the job that we're doing
because i want to do this and i would
never do this
i would never put so much time effort
and money into this project
yeah if it wasn't our job yeah and to me
that's like like something about that
like perfectly like
encapsulates doing this
right for us yeah because i feel like
typically when you hear people talk
about turning a hobby into a job it's
often negative
i wonder and i'm speaking about like
you know what most of who we've heard
from have been youtubers
yeah and i wonder if part of the reason
for that is a lot of
youtubers that started before we did
oftentimes they started the channel
itself
just for fun or as a hobby or just to
connect with people online or whatever
and then it became successful and then
they're
they're making money and they're like oh
i guess this is a business now
by the time we started youtube it was
very well known that it could be a
business and we went into it
hoping that it could be our job so that
we didn't have to work our nine to five
so we could spend our time together
doing something
creative and having fun and so i feel
like
um our experience is
very different yeah it might be for
someone who
you know again i'm being kind of
specific with channels
but whatever hobby your channel is
around like if they just started it just
for fun
this is this is an interesting thought
that i had and i was wondering where to
bring it up
but i think this might this might be a
good place
when when you are younger or you
yeah i don't know like if you're working
now and you have a boss
if you were about to do something
yourself
and you were taking the initiative to do
that and then someone comes in an
authority figure
and they say do that thing that you were
just about to do
you were excited you were about to do it
and then someone tells you to do it
kind of takes the wind out of your sails
a little bit kind of takes the wind out
of your sails a little bit right
yeah and i remember that feeling from
like like parents bosses parents bosses
any authority figure
it takes that initiative out of your
hands
yeah you know what i mean yeah and i
think that that's
a little bit of what happens when you
were making videos
all by yourself and you were doing it
just for fun
and then all of a sudden it's your job
and you have to do it in a way or you
feel like you have to do it
then like that's like an air quotes your
boss telling you to do it
yeah yeah that is interesting
so yeah i'm sure that's part of it too
yeah and i'm not fully sure how we have
been able to avoid that effect well i
think again because we
i think it's the same reason that i
brought up is we went into this
hoping we could turn it into a job like
we were never under the impression that
we would
do it just for fun here and there
like because it was a job all the way
right right out of the game yeah yeah
we always knew it was a job yeah even
like from the very beginning when we
were working our full-time job still we
were still posting three to four videos
a week
every week we were editing them to like
the highest quality we could
you know audio i know the audience
so bad but but we were doing the best we
could with what
we had and putting like full-time hours
into it even though you know we had our
regular job still two and so
it was always at like a very fast and
demanding
pace yeah we always felt an obligation
to do it because we wanted to make it
into a job
yeah that's interesting yeah i think the
the biggest thing
that's changed since we've turned our
hobbies into work
is we do our hobbies a lot more a lot
more just like that's the biggest
biggest change overall and since they
are all things that we like
that's the biggest the biggest bonus
because we're doing things that we like
so much more
um has have we done any of them oh
social media
okay well social media is not a hobby
but it is something that before
it was part of our job we did do we had
personal like social media accounts is
it weird
and i i'm not even sure if i should say
this but i'm just going to like
put those words out there and caitlyn
can help put them into like
context what are you about to say
it's it's it's
and it might just be because we have to
do social media all the time
but like i've kind of lost sight of why
i would want to do social media
yeah personally yeah and that's weird
for me to think of because like
like we we were early adopters of
facebook and
we were in the first batch of facebook
caitlyn was like oh all about
taking and sharing photos like she was
like the documentary of the like
whatever group she was in documentarian
yeah i don't know the prep word but i
was the one with the camera
yeah so any outing any whatever i would
i would take all the pictures
post them all on facebook tag everybody
we both enjoyed it we both loved social
media
yeah and it's weird that
now it
i don't know it's weird yeah i think
that maybe that's the thing because like
social media is like what happened to
social media is what a lot of people
worry happens when you turn your hobby
into a job
yeah like i did used to get some
enjoyment out of like
again you know um uh
this is a bit ago but like choosing like
fun filters for my instagram photos with
my friends and stuff like that you know
like i did used to get enjoyment out of
that and i think
i think in college when we were much
more
social with other people like
i i did feel an incentive to share
photos of hanging out with those people
in a way that those people could see the
photos yeah um
this is a weird this yeah this is a
weird thing because like we didn't
actually
plan to to ask this question but it's
weird so why
has like making crafting art games
like stayed good and positive as we've
turned them into work but like the
social media end of it
has like become less enticing to us
i think social media has evolved a lot
and i think like before we did it as
work
me personally like
i i didn't follow any
like influencer accounts or like
businesses at
all like i think i followed a couple
artists online that i had found and
liked
like from forever ago but it was other
than that it was just my friends
and so there
there is like incentive sharing things
with a small
group of friends but i feel like i have
a more
jaded view of social media overall
because of like influencer culture
and you know now we pretty much only
follow businesses we follow cool
businesses but you know you still see so
much more
of it and it feels more like
bragging or like oh i'm on
like i don't know like when we're doing
it for work it's like oh here's a
progress picture of something we're
working on
can't wait to share with you but i feel
like if i was doing it for a personal
thing
i i don't know how i would not feel like
i was trying to
like brag about something and maybe
that's because like it's so much more of
a highlight reel now than it was before
yeah yeah yeah cause like on facebook
you just post like
random photos kind of more yeah
yeah exactly like i just post full
albums of like
whatever party we went to you know it
wasn't like a curated
or like my trip to the zoo
yeah i don't know like you didn't you
weren't like
things weren't curated as much back in
my day
i know these youths posting their
highlights
things did start getting more curated
when instagram came around and it was
like oh you can't post more than one
instagram photo a day because then you
look like you're trying too hard so it
did kind of start evolving and i started
getting kind of annoyed with it
then even you know that's interesting
um and started slowing down
those like instagram posts even back
then but it's hard to say exactly i
don't know
honestly like of all of the things to
like
not really sour but like become just
work i'm glad that it was social media
instead of
making art gaming cooking filming
editing
and maybe part of that is because you
know we used to
what we would like i'd post on instagram
maybe once a week and
i pretty much stopped on facebook once
like i think it was like once
i moved to houston because then i
stopped like
having like big group outings where i
would need to share photos with a bunch
of people because that's what i had used
it for
yeah sharing photos with large groups
like large amounts of photos
this is another oh sorry i think like so
the point i was getting at though is
like even by the time we started the
channel i was maybe posting
on instagram once a week and that was it
so it was very low and then with this
because it's part of our jobs we're
posting every single day
on or almost every single day on
instagram twitter
um facebook we post on reddit like it
increased so much more than i naturally
would have
yeah so now it's just my social media
quote is overfilled
yeah yeah it's way over way over
whatever yeah yeah that's interesting
another potential is when did you start
art
when did you start doing art uh when i
was i mean i started trying it more
seriously when i was in like middle
school
but you you did art really young yeah
yeah yeah
but like i started like really trying in
school
when did you start playing games
much younger much younger yeah so gaming
and art and kind of making they're much
more ingrained in us
much more ingrained and part of our
identities yeah like yeah almost
30 years for some of these things you
know
and social media has only been part of
our lives
for like since however long facebook
came out
yeah yeah but like really we were doing
it
personally for not that long
yeah like maybe eight years i don't know
something like that yeah
but yeah like like because i really
started using it first year of college
yeah same so that's four years and then
we started our
evan and caitlyn job how how long after
i mean it doesn't matter
but yeah we we we did we did the making
crafting gaming that's been part of our
identity
our internal identity for so long
whereas social media
wasn't ever really part of our internal
identity no it was just like a
thing that we did every now and then
yeah because our friends did it
yeah but the weird thing okay no i'm
getting off the rails i'm kind of like
ruining
the like the the focus of the podcast
the thing that has been a core part of
our identity is
sharing what we made and that's been
something that we have loved
for the long time and still continues to
this day we get so excited during launch
day
we get so excited about like sharing
what we've made that's true well and to
to go back a little bit because people
might not know what you're talking about
we've probably mentioned this here or
there
either podcast or stream or i don't know
but did you spill tea
yeah it's okay i'll clean it up i'll
clean it up later okay
but you guys know that before
youtube we started a like just for fun
kind of blog
where we were sharing progress on our
house before that evan had a blog where
he shared games
i had a blog and funny memes i had a
blog where i was like
documenting my halloween decorations for
my apartment
and before that we both had art sharing
accounts on various websites yeah we
both shared our art online which i've
been doing since i was like 14.
yeah like so
like sharing things has been something
sharing things online has been something
both of us enjoyed
long before that would be considered a
hobby
i think it's like an extension of a
hobby yeah
i don't think sharing things online
itself
is a hobby but i feel like it's like an
aspect to
all of the hobbies that we do yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's like flavoring on top of
all of them
yeah and so that is something that we
have
extended and we didn't really think
about what about it when we decided to
start a youtube channel i don't think we
even made the connection until
like a year ago or so
like pretty recently and we were like oh
it makes sense why we enjoy this so much
because
we used to share stuff online all the
time
yeah and we really enjoyed that even
though we were both you know
doing it in a not anonymous way we had
like our usernames
it wasn't like tied to us personally as
much as something like youtube is
another thing that i want to touch on is
when when things were just a hobby
i already kind of touched on that one
gaming experience that i had where i
played games all day
and then i questioned my life afterwards
but like now that they're our work and
our hobbies
how do you feel after we finish spending
our time
doing that thing i feel great me too
i feel like i often have the thought of
like dang
we just got to play video games for
three hours and that was our job
we're like dang we just got to like cook
cook
we just got to make ourselves dinner and
that was our job we like made dinner
in our garage that was our job in our
set
like yeah like i i think that's a huge
difference it makes me very happy
like when since we've turned our hobbies
into work after i think we finished
doing that activity
i feel good like that was time well
spent it gives
more meaning to that time yeah and
maybe that's just something that's
important to weird people like us
maybe because we like spending our time
really efficiently
and we want our time to mean something
yeah and maybe that's not
the same for everyone but for us
it is yeah and i think that like a lot
of what we said like has been like
selling the idea of like turn your
hobbies into work
and feel guilty if you're not doing it
no don't
if you like doing hobbies and you're
just happy just doing them as a hobby
keep it that way i i think that
i just wanted to share our honest
experience with all of this because
people who had kind of like
lost time for their hobbies
yeah in a lot of ways yeah and this is
our way of bringing it back because
there's there's tons of people who have
jobs that they like and hobbies that
they like and they're glad that they're
separate
yeah um but we're definitely not for
everybody we're not those people we
we like and that's one reason we wanted
to talk about this because
again i feel like usually what you hear
is like oh
don't like be careful turning your
hobbies into work
you know because then it becomes work
and you lose the enjoyment
um yeah i'm trying to think of other
things
like some of the other stuff we touched
on i don't think there's as much on the
specific
things like we did used to film and edit
some little just for fun videos and we
don't really
do that anymore but yeah that was a very
very small thing we would do for like
vacations yeah we would try to take like
a second
every day and like at the end of the
year i'll try to like edit them
together into like just flashes of life
blowing past you to like
make you remember what you did with your
life but i think one reason i feel less
motivated
to even though i would like to do that
one reason i feel less motivated to is
our life is so documented in video form
already
also like it goes back to what i was
saying with the what's new in the
beginning it's like
we haven't done the what's new segment
of the podcast for so long because
what's new
it's all documented we made all these
videos
and lived our life in between them just
doing doing life stuff you know yeah one
thing that's interesting is
and i'm curious to get your thoughts on
on this too yeah
before we turned our hobbies into work
so we talked about how he felt after
them
how do you feel before doing them
thinking about doing it like
are you excited to do them more or less
um i i will say sometimes it depends on
the
mood i'm in but it's not really because
the thing is a hot it's a hobby
yeah so like there are some times where
like if we're you know usually if we are
like
really tired or just kind of out of it
we we
have enough flexibility in our day that
we don't have to
film on those days or we don't have to
stream on those days
um but back when our days were more
packed and we couldn't just
not film in a day you know there have
been times where like
we'd be super tired because we were up
really late the night before and it's
like oh i got to be
energetic now going into this thing and
if
if we weren't filming it for a video
then i could do it without being
energetic yeah you know um or we just
probably would do it or
yeah or you just wouldn't do it but then
it goes back to just not doing yeah
um that's really the closest like thing
i can think
of that is a negative yeah so sometimes
if we had no time pressure on it well
bobby i think it goes back to the thing
is like we just wouldn't do these things
as much um but we just do them because
we kind of
that is our job and most of the time
we're very excited about it yeah
it's just when we're really tired yeah
yeah i i agree with that
and i think that like one reason why i
am excited to do them
is because we're doing something fairly
fun for
work yeah and the novelty and the
coolness of that
makes me pretty excited about that yeah
as a bonus on top of something that was
already a hobby
and maybe it depends on like
maybe it depends on why you did your
hobbies before
like if you know maybe if the whole
point of you
doing art was to have like quiet time
and that's the reason you did it
that's a very different reason than like
like a big
part of my reason for doing art is
because i liked to share it online and i
was like
ooh i hope i get some comments on this
one you know what i mean how about
like 1000. if like art was your escape
and that was
yeah that was how you quieted your mind
and then all of a sudden you have to be
energetic and on for the camera then i
can see how
you might build up some resentment yeah
oh this that's that's an interesting
thing because like one thing i like
doing is playing games with friends
and when we game it feels like playing
games with friends
but yeah like having chat with us
feels like we're playing with a big
group yeah like hanging out in the
living room
yeah it's a similar vibe whereas like if
you
preferred games you know i guess like a
lot of games i
played were more solo games so i'm
slightly different but
you know if if games were like you're
chill quiet
wind down time and then all of a sudden
you're like i have to i have to talk the
whole time i'm playing
you know i could see how that would make
you enjoy them less
yeah so yes it may be part of it's like
how you enjoyed those hobbies
yeah and do you have to do them in a
different
in a way that is not compatible yeah how
you used to enjoy them
what's the biggest surprise that you've
had
about turning hobbies into work that you
just didn't see coming
or you thought it would go a different
way biggest surprise
um if you want some more time i can go
first i think okay you go first
i wanted to give you the room just in
case okay now you go
the biggest surprise for me and i think
i knew it to a certain degree i was just
surprised by how much
there's the saying that i completely
disagree with now
but it's something that everyone has
heard and i heard a lot
growing up and i think that i think it's
a complete lie
even though it's i don't know i'll just
say
do what you love and you'll never work a
day in your life
i very much disagree with that and the
the level of
that that i disagree with it was
surprising because
what it is more is
do what you love for work and you'll
always be working
but you'll like it yeah
yeah and that's good and bad
yeah i mean
there's definitely less motivation to
take breaks even when it might be
healthy for us
because it's like we really want to
do something that is work related a
streaming is a really good example
like we um
like we are often tempted to stream more
but we're like
but if we stream then we're gonna be up
we're gonna have to stay up really late
editing
and we don't want to be up really late
editing so we need to
like wait till tomorrow to stream you
know that's a very simplified
example but it's like we have too many
good things in our life that we want to
do
yeah and we just prioritize a lot of the
work things
um and we're we've been trying to pull
back on works that we have more time
not work but it's also hard because it's
really hard to pull back we we're doing
what we like
for our job we're getting paid for it
we're we're finding success at it all
and it's hard to stop doing that it's
really hard
um and that was something i didn't see
coming yeah
yeah and it's not necessarily all bad no
i mean i think it's
it's like a good problem to have like oh
i like my work so much that i have a
hard time stopping working
and like honestly right now everyone's
kind of stuck at home anyway and so like
we aren't
facing it like the issue of it quite as
much
i think this is another hard thing to
communicate the nuance of this
people some people might think well then
you're not working you're doing what you
like
but it's still work it's still work yeah
and that's a hard thing to communicate
unless i think you've
done it maybe i don't know i i'm not i'm
not sure if i have the words
and the insight and the nuance like i'm
wearing my words are hard
shirt right now for those of you who are
just listening i'm wearing this because
i very much agree
that words are hard and it's hard to to
in a nuanced way explain
why it still work but it's work that we
like
yeah i think it's because
like uh
like if if someone was like oh well
you're just
you know you're just playing with resin
and playing video games all day that's
not work
that kind of discounts all the other
stuff that
happens around it or like the way
in which we do it that
like that we do specifically because
it's work
yeah how about this like i don't know
i'm about to come up with like and this
is dangerous territory for me
i'm gonna use a sports analogy guess who
knows nothing about
me i know nothing about sports imagine
you love playing basketball
and you're really good at it and you
just like playing basketball and you
just do it whenever you want
you do it with whoever you want and you
have no commitments around it
but all of a sudden you you decide to go
pro
and you start like working at like the
little
like whatever like minor league
basketball there is and you start like
your goal is nba
or whatever and all of a sudden you're
still playing basketball but you have to
travel
you have to start your social media
accounts and you have to like
do public relations and you have to you
know
you have to train and you have a
schedule and you have a coach
telling you what to do and you're no
longer playing with whoever you want
you get transferred and you lose the
team members that you like
and this is this is going like much
farther it's kind of breaking down
our example i don't know it's it's it's
uh
yeah i don't know i don't have the right
analogy for for
for this i think it's hard because like
some of the stuff you know there's
obviously
like back end stuff that we wouldn't
choose to do like emailing
people and things like that you know
stuff that is truly more of the work all
the business stuff
all the business stuff but you know
sometimes we
will have a day where like our entire
day is
filming and streaming like none of the
business stuff
and so taking the business stuff out of
it
why oh yeah yeah still
work because it is it does still feel
like work and part of it might be
because there are things you're doing
differently
like um it's like we're doing this resin
pour that we enjoy
but at the same time you're keeping
track of like what the next five steps
are
so that we don't miss something i'm
keeping track of how long have we been
talking about this oh we need to switch
camera angles
and like there's other things we're
keeping track of in our heads so we're
not only
doing the resin pour we're also like
doing all these other things
i came up with a weird thought okay
is it another sports analogy no this is
about just what we do
okay okay um
but i'm trying to get my words right but
like
i think one of the things is our
results are judged you know like we are
trying to come up with a specific thing
like
the reason why it's work is because when
we're making it we do multiple takes if
we don't get the intro right
we go back and get b-roll we're not just
out there making in real time
there's a lot of behind-the-scenes stuff
that we do like while we're making out
there it's like
up get get the cameras turned on put on
the mic oh i don't know if we
got that intro should we edit it real
quick edit it real quick yeah
okay and then in the end we want to come
up with a good video
and i think that we like this is weird
to say but i think we like being judged
because that's how you win because
that's how you win yeah
you know but like it's also weird i
think one reason like
and i'm just being honest here one
reason why we like it
is because we're winning yeah aka like
the business is successful the business
is successful
yeah honestly if and that's why people
burn out if our
channel was dying if our videos were
doing well if we were getting
people coming into our channel saying
like i you
you like watching you do do this makes
me
upset i don't know all right i'm like
if we weren't winning at least
an acceptable degree not that like our
subscribers have to be shooting out not
that like
all of our metrics have to be green
green green but just like like
we're getting positive feedback the
videos are performing at a rate that we
see as being good and there's an overall
upward trend
yeah honestly i'm just being
no i think i think if like it was
opposite of that if there was a downward
trend if the
all like videos over and over and over
again weren't performing how we liked it
i wouldn't be motivated to do this
yeah we wouldn't we wouldn't be
motivated because it is a lot of work
yeah then it would really feel like a
job
yeah you know it's like oh we just got
to keep on doing this even though people
don't like it
yeah but but you're totally right there
is that like constant
pressure to do well
that is in your your brain every time
you're
filming or streaming like maybe that's
what makes it kind of like
work and so and going back to the other
states going back to the basketball
analogy
if you win the game versus lose it if
you're playing professionally yeah
they're stakes they're stakes and that's
why you're playing it professionally
first if you're just playing a pickup
game
yeah but i think i think they're being
stakes is
is part of it yeah that's what makes it
good and that's what makes it work
and that's what makes it bad potentially
yeah
although there's pressure for it to not
be bad yeah
yeah that is that's interesting
yeah i hadn't i hadn't considered that
was there is there any more stuff about
like doing hobbies as your work
that you want to cover i don't know i
went off on a whole bunch of tangents
but i
i think i'm ready to move on like if if
you guys have any follow-up questions
for us
leave them in the comments or or use the
the podcast form
we're collecting like questions and
answers type questions
and everything for a future podcast
always so
so we'll we'll keep an eye on those and
everything
but i think that we covered it pretty
well yeah i think we covered it even
more than i thought because i had like
insights as we spoke on this yeah yeah
should we move on to our thing of the
week
no no i have more questions oh two more
questions okay so you weren't done i
thought you
i thought you said you were done well no
just with that segment of it okay
okay sorry so what else might we
want to turn into work so that we can
make more of it like have you ever
thought like
okay oh you know gaming's worked out
cooking has worked out making crafting
art has worked out
what's another thing that we can add to
like do more of that we can justify by
making it work
i have one thing okay so i'll go first
since i'm just hitting you with this
fresh
okay technology
i don't know what to do with it but i
love technology i like
like buying it i like researching it i
like testing it i like
comparing it all that stuff and i've
thought in the past like maybe i'll do
like an unboxing
a tech channel a review channel but i
don't don't want to do that i don't know
so in interest that's an interesting
example because
if we zoomed out the camera right now
you would see a huge amount of
technology oh evan's going to do it
or you're going to expose us oh the
green screen exposed
you will see a huge amount of technology
around us sorry
sorry listeners that has been
accumulated over the past
this is just like a year and a half
since we started streaming and
podcasting
yeah um but you know we're often
upgrading
camera related stuff lighting related
stuff sound related stuff and so i think
like
i think you've been able to scratch that
itch in some ways yeah
um because you know we do
need a lots of technology for you i've
even been able to incorporate into some
videos like
3d printing kind of scratched the ditch
because i'm like getting 3d printers and
messing with 3d printers or
like um when we did the underwater
stream i got to mess with a lot of fun
technology there and that was
very satisfying to me you've got to
learn a lot about like programming
custom leds and stuff yeah
but like i'm not sure if i'd be excited
to film
a review video yeah just because like
that would need to serve a certain
purpose i'd have to do like i'd have to
like
make graphics and lists and list specs
and stuff like that
do you like computers maybe just like
maybe maybe just unboxing
and first impressions and just playing
with it nothing formal as a review just
like
oh look at this look at this i don't
know
yeah or like tech roundups and is it
but i'm not even sure if i'll be excited
like tech round off what's the hobby in
this case is it just buying technology
is the hobby buying technology if all
you're doing is unboxing because it's
not like unboxing technology i kind of
like buying some technology
you heard it here he admits it i like
buying technology i know this about you
i knew this when i'm very
i i have that little tiny computer over
there i have another tiny computer on
the way
oh it's fun yeah maybe it's just yeah
maybe just
my hobby is buying and messing with
technology
uh um so let's see if i if i was gonna
do anything like if i think about the
stuff that i might want to try
um making into content
it's not necessarily hobbies i have
it's stuff that i think would
well it's a mixture of things so some
things are stuff that i think would be
fun but we wouldn't do it without the
excuse of it being a video
like i do your makeup yeah like ev like
my boyfriend does my makeup well your
husband but you know what i mean i just
like i enjoy watching those
videos when it's like a couple that i
like their personalities like in a way
that is like strangely like a hobby that
you have like
that is that that is like um
the two of us spending time together
that's something we enjoy spent you know
that's what we like using our time on
and making videos yeah
that's true and like if i'm gonna go
even farther down that rabbit hole
like the stuff i would really enjoy is
because i'm like i'm very into
uh halloween and so i've gone down some
real deep rabbit holes with like super
cool halloween makeup or like
you know like when we did like our
skeleton skeleton makeup things like
that
um where it's like a little bit more
like art
and i think that would be just really
fun to do
i don't know i like that kind of stuff
all right maybe we'll we'll find
in the the long-term future i think
right now i'm happy
with where we're at this is all
hypothetical hypothetical yeah it's all
hypothetical so like but that that is
an example yeah of something i would
like
to do but it's not really a hobby i
would just like it to be a hobby
seems fun all right one last question on
this and then
then time for thing of the week i i
don't know this i'm going to read it
right now will we continue to enjoy the
hobbies we've chosen for the rest of our
career
i mean i think making things
art and video games have been like we
said in the beginning those have all
been things we've
enjoyed for a long
time technically for me
making things has been the most recent i
didn't really get into it till
i got my first apartment and i wanted to
start making decor for myself
art and gaming have been like for as
long as i can remember yeah
and we can always add art into making to
like
satisfy that part yeah but i i feel
pretty confident with
like the the array we've chosen and i
think that
one thing and and this might be like a
more applicable tip
to people who are thinking about doing
this how do you add that variety to
whatever hobby you're doing
to make it something that'll last that
long because for us
from the beginning we wanted diversity
we wanted like even within
even when we were just making we did
like you know woodworking
metal working a little bit um like all
these different things we didn't just do
one thing
and then we added in like resin and
cheese
and art and like you know like all these
things and the gaming and there's a
variety and there's spice and like when
we've done one thing for a while i'm
excited to do the other and
there's like yeah but i do think that if
we have chosen one thing
and like like let's say that we loved
collecting pens
or just making pens and we made a pen
making channel
and it got pretty successful i just
tried to choose a very very specific
thing
yeah well yeah yeah i'm not sure if you
could do that for 20 years
50 years i don't know how long we're
gonna work yeah i mean
i i think like an interesting um
as you were talking about that i did
start i was thinking about the variety
in our channel
and how like for the first year and a
half of our channel
you know how like if you're describing a
channel to someone it's like oh
this is evan and caitlin they do this um
like we noticed oftentimes every time we
would do a collaboration with someone
and they would like
pitch our channel to their viewers or if
we were like at events
and people like oh you guys are having
caitlyn you do these videos right it was
always
cnc tnt first yep it was like oh you
guys do cnc videos
and then resin no oh yeah well then
resin came later yeah but but my point
is
like you know we were doing a lot of cnc
videos in the beginning
of our youtube yeah career because
we had a cnc and it was something like
not tons of people
had back then a lot of people more
people have them now um
and so it was like oh they had their
it's like they make stuff on the cnc and
things like that
and now you would not i don't think you
would describe our channel in that way
you might call us the resin channel
that's like the kick we're on right now
but we've left things
open enough that we can we can for a
little bit be the cnc
channel we can for a little bit be the
resin art channel we can for a little
bit be whatever
the new trend we fall down
on that that's not that's not the right
way to say whatever
you want to say great words great words
um
but yeah so we have left it we we set it
up so it was pretty open
yes so it's future proof it's i think
it's pretty future proof
on that note it's time for thing of the
week
okay so my thing of the week
is food related um okay
so i'm getting hungry just thinking
about it honestly i want some
right now so um you know
i don't have that many like treat
yourself splurges
really and if i think about the ones
that i do have
they are often something that i eat
um and one of those things is
java chips so we we both were first
introduced to java chips
because my excitement voice we were both
first introduced to hoffenheim's when we
because we both had lived in california
at different points in our lives
and they're pretty big over there um you
can just find them in the grocery store
i think here you can
maybe in texas you can maybe find them
at like special specialty food places
yeah fancy places um
but you can't get them at like h-e-b um
which is where we typically go
but uh you can order them online
in what like a 24 pack it's it's a lot
it's like
like if you're gonna be ordering them
from amazon you're taking a big leap of
faith
from our recommendation but like i would
say we'll link to the amazon listing
because that's where we buy them
see if you can find them in like a
single pack see if you can find a single
pack to try them out because they
are different from any other tortilla
chip
oh these are tortilla chips by the way
they're not like potato chips
they're tortilla chips but they're
cooked with soy sauce
not too much no just a hint just a hint
just a little it gives them
like just this very interesting and i
even say there's something else going on
there's something like a real good corn
taste real good corn real like like
they're they're so
the unique thing is like that hint of
soy sauce they're the only corn ship
that i can eat just just as like almost
a snack
sometimes i'll just go out and like have
like four chips but yet they also don't
overpower
salsas or guac because there's some
things like julio's
chips oh yeah are really good but
there's so much seasoning sometimes it
kind of over julio's you just eat all by
themselves
exactly okay so for those of you guys
who live in texas julios are
highly salty super salty super flavored
tortilla chips living in texas where
there's
so many choices so many tortilla chip
options y'all in
in texas i do get sad when we've been so
many tortillas
options oh so good um california's got
so good pretty good pretty yeah pretty
good um anyways we're getting off topic
but
um java chips so good we buy a 24 pack
at on amazon it's kind of expensive
um so you know buy at your own risk but
they're so freaking good
have apostrophe a
corn chips have they're they we call
them java
but they're they're have a i don't know
why do we call them i've always heard
them called java ever since they were
first introduced to me
well because i call them java chips
because my mom called them havoc
but i had them before you too really
yeah i had them before
well i'm pretty sure that like they're
called java chips because my mom
grew up near the original java chips
like the original place where they were
made
like it was a single store so you're in
laguna beach
and she grew up there and like that's
where they came from yeah so
she talked to the people who worked at
the original java chip that's so crazy
factory
or i don't know i don't know what it was
it was just like a little store
so tasty okay anyways let's stop talking
about food so that everyone can stop
drooling
my thing of the week is a kickstarter
project that we backed
and it's finally here ah it's so
beautiful it's um
simone's everyday calendar it
is a good shout out she did such a good
job with this the quality
the cnc'd-ness the electronics anyways
let's describe what it is for people who
might not have seen it
it is a habit tracker and um it's
basically a calendar
with lights behind every day
and every day you do something you tap
it and that day lights up
so that eventually over a year hopefully
you fill
the entire calendar with whatever good
habit
by presenting whatever good habit you're
trying so tying it back to the very
beginning we're probably going to be
using it to track our workouts so that
every day we work out
we touch the calendar and it glows
nicely and we have to both do it so it's
incentive for both of us to do it
otherwise it's dim it'll stay dim for a
year
um and it's i'm just really impressed by
the
the outer board of it is like
a circuit board kind of yeah
and the car you're touching the contacts
of a circuit board
and it's not the style it's just
function yeah oh yeah yeah but i know
like it's like
you know when you picture a circuit
board you're not going to picture what
this looks like it's really
the front is really well designed well
thought out and the
the um the uh the bamboo
is like it's like cnc'd bamboo plywood
and that just is an awesome material
looks really cool
um and uh yeah i'm just i'm just really
happy with it yeah so
is one of the first kickstarter i think
is that the first kickstarter we
personally ever backed
i think it might be yeah yeah that's
cool
that was cool want to support him she
went through a lot of
like trials and tribulations with like
supply chains and
you know the pandemic going on videos on
our channel that documented that are
pretty interesting too if you want to
see behind the scenes it's pretty cool
but
we have it it looks really cool i'm
excited to get using it so that's my
thing of the week
all right guys well this was a little
bit longer of a podcast than i
than i thought i was like we had a lot
to say we had the
the card games ready to go just in case
we ran out of like things to say
but we certainly don't need that um but
i hope you guys enjoyed it again let us
know if you have any questions down in
the comments below
also if you didn't wouldn't mind like
leaving a
you know five-star rating perhaps where
on whatever
um podcast app you're using if the the
loudest rating
i think that like i want to pull this
like
long-term prank on just people i want
random people to find this podcast and
be confused yep cause they don't know
who we are
random people out there i just like the
idea of that
kind of just makes me happy yeah i feel
like we're trolling
people browsing for podcasts um anyways
i hope you're having a great day out
there
um and we'll look forward to seeing you
in the next video bye
that was good yeah that was really fun